corta primero hace una raya vertical
ataúdes rudimentarios fabricados en
serie en plena calle desde hace algunas
semanas se volvió una escena van al mar
y no tiene un minuto para perder los
pedidos incrementaron desde que la
presencia de la variante sudafricana de
1 351 fue confirmada mediante
secuenciación
a veces no hay pedidos
a veces uno al día
pero desde esta pandemia hay muchos a
veces recibimos 10 pedidos al día
el viernes recibimos 20
[Música]
para absorber el flujo de enfermos
hoteles y escuelas fueron transformados
en hospitales en este liceo todos los
enfermos se encuentran con oxígeno el
problema es que en caso de corte de
electricidad o recalentamiento del
aparato se detiene a mediados de abril
algunos enfermos fallecieron tras un
corte de energía
eugene acaba de perder a su cuñado tras
la detención repentina de un
concentrador ubicación en el ataúd
desinfección en el patio del elíseo los
entierros deben hacerse dentro de 24
horas para evitar contagios
tras la tristeza mucha rabia por una
atención que considera deficiente el
oxígeno se detuvo cuando nos habían
dicho que compramos una medicina en otro
lado porque no la tenían cuando
regresamos los médicos le dieron el
medicamento pero el oxígeno se detuvo
llamé a un enfermero pero no le
preocupaba luego le supliqué venir a ver
a nuestro familiar porque sufría lo
triste es la negligencia porque llamamos
al personal nos respondieron que estaban
haciendo una pausa tan solo ayer
murieron nueve personas aquí
nueve fallecimientos tan solo en este
liceo en una jornada a pesar de ello las
cifras oficiales mencionaran seis
muertos al día siguiente lo mismo ocurre
en esta pequeña empresa familiar
revelaciones cada día se lado a la
carroza fúnebre rápidamente las llamadas
son numerosas a veces hay que rechazar
solicitudes
tenemos como mínimo dos muertos por kobe
está al día pero pueden ser cuatro antes
sólo lo hacíamos lunes miércoles y
viernes porque según la tradición de
madagascar sólo se entierra los martes y
los jueves pero actualmente lo hacemos
todos los días de lunes a domingo
siempre hay un entierro nos sorprenden
las cuentas oficiales si nos sorprende
mucho lo que vivimos la situación real
con respecto a las cuentas oficiales
no es lo mismo nos sorprenden esas
estadísticas las que vemos en televisión
para las autoridades la situación está
bajo control cuando se le pregunta al
respecto al ministro de salud pierde la
paciencia no no no hay muertos por todas
partes no estoy de acuerdo
no hay muertos por todas partes porque
hablan de lo que no han visto
hay muertos lo acepto la cantidad
aumentado y tal vez hay muertos que no
hayamos visto es cierto pero no es tanto
como usted lo dice tú no
en la oficina municipal de higiene de la
capital que registra las declaraciones
de fallecimientos no se había visto un
pico ha sido desde la epidemia de cólera
en 1999
el presidente de madagascar anunció la
construcción de 13 hospitales en las
regiones y 110 centros de salud rurales
la variante sudafricana es difícil de
contener porque es 50 veces más
contagiosa que el virus inicial
asistimos a formas cada vez más graves
que son mortales muy rápido porque
llegan a pequeños vasos de órganos
nobles
y ahí es donde la variante genera
problemas en las formas graves
es triste ver a personas caer como
moscas porque creían estoy habituado a
tener gripa dolores de cabeza
es fulminante tal como se lo dije los
vasos lanzan pequeñas redes que tapan
las arterias y no hay circulación a
nivel cerebral y del corazón y mueren
un virus fulgurante que degenera en
enfermedad del sistema los
investigadores lo habían anunciado hace
un año para hacerle frente el presidente
le apostó al cb o más una pastilla a
base de plantas elogiada como un remedio
milagroso pero como la segunda ola llegó
tan repentinamente las autoridades
pidieron la vacuna con urgencia
mientras tanto elisa necesita una
ambulancia equipada de oxígeno para su
hermano necesitamos hacer un escáner en
otro lugar pero desafortunadamente la
ambulancia del centro no tiene oxígeno
una ambulancia privada cuesta 45 euros
no contamos con los recursos
en este momento debemos hacer muchos
exámenes cuyo precio oscila entre 7
euros y 8 euros con 80 cada uno entonces
no tenemos dinero para pagar una
ambulancia
nos interrumpe un responsable se ha dado
la orden de no mostrarles la otra cara
de la moneda a los periodistas oxígeno
racionado escasez de medicinas personal
desbordado difícil luchar en igualdad de
condiciones contra una de las variantes
más temidas del planeta